Hello Freak bitches.
That's amazing.
What do you think he walked away with?
Oh,
he took 10 up front to make it.
He probably got a ton of money.
I don't know how it works.
Points.
He's probably got 30,
30 million out of that.
Maybe balling out of control crews.
Hit us up,
dude.
Yeah,
he's good friends with dom.
Irrera yeah,
those too.
That's so funny.
I would love to see it.
Just a dumb too in a diner having a conversation.
I know,
right?
It's this Bruce.
The dama rare.
Tom.
I rarer still doing the day.
I do.
I fucking love him.
He did a bunch of episodes on the showtime show identity.
Yeah.
Dude,
it's fucking so awesome that they got like real comics,
man.
The showtime show looks great,
Love how authentic everybody looks and the hairstyles
it real comics.
Y'all magical.
You drawn Erik Griffin.
Giran uh,
um,
fucking dumb.
Earl Skakel does a few Poppins on it.
Um,
oh my God.
Oh,
I'm drum drawing such a blank.
There's so many other guys that like came in and left.
She already fucking gold.
Yeah,
that's that man.
That's crazy.
And Melissa's mullets,
you guys and Leo
feel like an extreme amount of responsibility while you were doing this because
you're doing a movie that's based on the most important comedy club in my
opinion.
Ever.
Yeah.
TV show,
but yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're doing a show.
The pressure was fucking,
yeah man.
I felt the pressure,
the responsibility was fucking huge.
Wow.
We premiered last night and it will air this Sunday and uh,
Jim Carrey said some amazing things,
man.
Yeah.
That's our cast photo.
That one that you clicked that one.
Yeah.
Did it feel weird to be on that?
I mean it must have been like,
I can tell you from the bottom of my honest heart,
it was the most important thing I've done so far.
Wow.
Dude.
I mean we're paying homage to the world that,
that we love and respect so much.
And it was a big effort on Jim's part and his producing partner,
Michael Aguilar to like tell real stories.
A lot of the stories that people will see if you watch the show,
and I hope you do come from Jim's real life to do term Boston moved.
They live in a fucking dude's closet in West Hollywood and they used to be a guy
that would jerk off and watched him change and that's Cim put that story in the
show,
man.
He wanted all these little great tidbit.
There's a great moment about jokes stealing in there and a fucking huge fist
fight that breaks out.
That was real from gyms,
personal life about guys who used to come in from the fucking radio,
from talk radio in the,
you know,
in the morning they come to the club at night,
come to the store,
steal shit.
The next morning comics would fucking hear it.
Yeah.
That's a real common thing.
Yeah,
man.
Right.
That was always going on.
You know what else was going on?
A big one was,
uh,
writers for sitcoms would come.
Yup.
Same Shit.
And they would watch people do sets and then they would wind up putting their,
their bits and like even in fucking Seinfeld,
Kevin,
when Kevin James Signature bits got used on Seinfeld after he had a bunch of
meetings and then they came to see him perform a bunch of like top writers came
to see him performing an NBC showcase this like when Kevin was getting a
development deal and they came down and watched him and then like the next,
his
muffin bit was on a Seinfeld episode and he was like,
what the fuck man?
Well nowadays they fucking,
they're blatant.
They tell you like I,
I tested for Saturday night live and you sign a form that says these characters
can be used after the audition.
Whoa.
And this is crazy.
I'm not calling out anybody or saying anything,
but they did.
There was a character ended up on the show that Vanessa Bayer did fucking
hilariously,
that I did something similar in my edition.
I was like,
damn,
that was really good.
It's winning me.
You so you,
you audition,
you have a character you audition with.
Yeah.
I did this character,
this fake work deals that they own that now when you audition,
you surrender the character.
Fuck you man.
Yeah.
You signed a piece of paper when it's crazy.
They're not even giving you money and they're stealing your idea.
Then when you get that,
that's the respect that,
uh,
the SNL has earned in the,
in that community who,
you know,
you don't have that respect.
It's crazy.
That's stealing.
You're stealing.
Well,
I signed the form,
man.
Oh my God.
Dude,
that's so awful.
I signed that sheet because of the May,
cause you can almost taste it.
You know,
they're making you sign something saying we're going to steal from you.
Totally.
That's insane.
We're going to steal from you.
We're not going to pay you anything.
We're going to use this thing.
It might be a fucking Mike Meyers movie someday and you'd have to say,
yes sir.
May I have another take it and take gas.
Can I dig it?
It's so crazy.
I took it,
man.
I took it.
It was a wild process,
but the fact that some she usually successful business wouldn't want to
compensate people for creating those ideas to fly you out to,
to show yourself off in a few.
I mean even if you just don't hire them but you liked that character,
you there should be like an established rate that you have to pay for things.
But I mean not you don't,
and my whole thing is like,
I'm not saying what they did was what I did,
but it was,
there was some similarities in the nuances of the character that I thought were
either just a confluence of great ideas,
but um,
it is hard.
You think about that stuff.
You're like,
man,
is that close to what I did?
Because you know,
like we said back in the day,
like our show shows,
people were blatantly steal.
People have been blatantly stealing in comedy for fucking ever.
It's been like the beginning of time,
and especially in the 70s which I think is what we tried to show was like they
would steal these radio guys and fucking show up again and be like,
hey,
like it was like it happen on buddy told him that that was one of your shit
jokes from last night.
We always,
we always promote you.
You ever,
you're in town.
Yeah.
[inaudible].